un navire de recherches sismiques des
pêchés au large par la turquie en
méditerranée orientale
ce bateau doit explorer une zone dont
les sols sont riches en hydrocarbures
qui s'étend de la crête grande île
grecque au sud jusqu'à quelques
kilomètres de la station balnéaire
turque d'antalya ces gisements
potentiels attise les tensions avec les
pays riverains dont la grèce qui
revendique une zone maritime exclusive
attendant le qu'on se le dise le risque
d'accident est plus présent quand de
tels moyens militaires sont réunis dans
une zone aussi confiné dans un tel cas
la responsabilité incombe à celui qui
est à l'origine de cette situation
nous restons fermes dans notre
engagement en faveur de la légalité
internationale et du pouvoir la
diplomatie pour résoudre les problèmes
les plus complexes
nous ne serons jamais ce qui aggraveront
la situation pourtant la retenue n'est
qu'un aspect de notre pouvoir
aucune provocation ne restera cependant
sans réponse
nous avons démontré que nous répondrons
si nous nous sentons obligés et nous le
ferons à nouveau si nécessaire
mais la turquie compte est la
délimitation de l'espace maritime
grecque
ankara conteste le fait que le rocher de
kastellorizo maïs pour les turcs coller
à ses côtes
servat délimiter son espace maritime et
donc son champ d'action ils revendiquent
une souveraineté maritime en se servant
de l'île de metz situé à deux kilomètres
des côtes turques et vous savez à quelle
distance de la grèce métropolitaine 580
km cela ne peut s'expliquer
rationnellement
cela n'a pas de sens le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan a demandé à
s'entretenir avec la chancelière
allemande angela merkel et le président
du conseil européen charles michel pour
chercher à apaiser les tensions en
méditerranée orientale
une première tentative d'exploration
turc avait été stoppée il ya quelques
semaines à la suite de pressions de
l'allemagne
de son côté la france a renforcé sa
présence militaire dans la zone
en déployant temporairement deux
chasseurs rafale en crète et deux
navires de la marine nationale en
méditerranée orientale
j'ai décidé de renforcer temporairement
la présence militaire française en
méditerranée orientale dans les
prochains jours
en coopération avec les partenaires
européens dont la grèce le chef de
l'état a vivement critiqué ce qu'ils
considèrent comme des violations de
souveraineté grecque et chypriote par la
turquie au sujet de l'exploration de ses
ressources gazières et appelle les deux
frères ennemis de l'otan à se concerter
davantage pour apaiser les tensions
emmanuel dupuis président le leap seul
institut prospective et sécu très en
europe ou décrypte les enjeux derrière
cette ruée vers les hydrocarbures en
méditerranée orientale
l'été dernier en juillet 2010 par le
bateau donc qu'il l'objet de la
polémique aujourd'hui le bateau
d'exploration 6 lecture hors ukraine
avait décelé que cette partie de la
méditerranée située entre la grèce la
turquie chypre et les deux crêtes
pouvait déceler près de 50 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz près de 1,5 milliard
de barils de pétrole
ce qui avec la perspective de la
création d'un gazoduc qui relie l'egypte
à la grèce et donc dé facto offrant une
alternative au gaz au dock turc
permettrait de être moins dépendants
pour nous européens de la turquie d'une
part et d'autre part de montrer que
cette partie de la méditerranée mérite
effectivement une concertation plus
fortes sont en tout cas plus réelle
qu'elle n'a été jusqu'à présent